president Trump meets with Secretary of
State Mike Pompeo this morning Pompeyo
report at least preparing for his third
trip to North Korea later this week to
discuss a proposed timeline for full D
nuclearization of the Korean Peninsula
Paula Reed is at the White House where
another top official says that will
happen quickly Paula good morning good
morning Gail now Washington and
Pyongyang have yet to nail down any
specific details about exactly how North
Korea will denuclearize and as for a
timeline a lot of questions there too is
a National Security Advisor says all of
this will happen within a year but the
Secretary of State says it's gonna be
more like two and a half years I made a
deal with him
President Trump told Fox News Sunday he
trusted Kim jong-un would dismantle his
nuclear program but admitted the deal
they agreed to in Singapore last month
could fall apart have I been in deals
have you been in things where people
didn't work out it's possible that's far
from the president's confident tone
arriving home from the summit there is
no longer a nuclear threat but new
satellite imagery shows expansion of a
missile manufacturing site capable of
producing missiles that could hit US
military installations in Asia the North
Koreans were finishing construction of
the plant around the same time President
Trump was meeting with Kim in Singapore
it goes to show the intentions and
expectations that the North Koreans had
going into the meeting David schmurder
is a researcher at the Middlebury
Institute it shows that they're fully
committed to maintaining their ballistic
missile program this comes on top of a
Washington Post report that US
intelligence believed that the North
Koreans are planning to conceal the
number of warheads in their arsenal I
don't want to comment on that specific
report on Sunday's Face the Nation the
president's national security advisor
john bolton would not address the
reporting arguing the administration had
a plan to fully dismantle the nuclear
program we have developed a program I'm
sure that Secretary of State Mike Pompeo
will be discussing this with the North
Koreans in the near future about really
how to dismantle all of their WMD and
ballistic missile programs in a year
behind the scenes the diplomacy Kim
news over the weekend a US envoy met
with North Koreans in the DMZ the
National Security Advisor also says no
matter what is negotiated North Korea
must be required to fully disclose all
of its nuclear programs and its
ballistic missile sites something that
has not happened just yet Anthony Paula
thanks